reject nation we are back for a very
special koi's comic corner this is the
first that immediately follows a movie
because we are going to talk about those
post-credits scenes but before we do
that please leave a like subscribe hit
that bell do all the youtube things and
also leave that app and follow me on
tick tocks i'm gonna do a lot of these
on tik tok as well 15 seconds one minute
three minutes all sorts of things and on
saturday we are going to be doing a full
length spoiler talk so what we're going
to talk about today are those two
post-credits scenes we're going to talk
about how they set up phase five how
they set up thor five what they mean for
the future of marvel in general then
we're gonna give some comic
recommendations on those very characters
and what that means for the greater mcu
as a whole these were two of my favorite
post-credits scenes in phase four
sometimes it feels like a post-credits
scene is there because they're popular
sometimes it feels like marvel's like oh
we've gotta do a post-credit scene these
didn't feel like that these felt
intentional these felt like they were
set up in the script these felt like
they weren't just a gimmick they were
something special as well as a
connecting tissue to the future of the
mcu which to me is what a post-credit
scene should be i enjoy captain america
sitting down and being cheeky at me
staying here but i'd prefer hercules
getting a debut i love when new
characters are introduced we had a new
character introduced in the last five
minutes of this movie that i think is
very important for the young avengers
but that's another video i'm gonna talk
about that and how this all ties into
the future of guardians and everything
else so the first post-credit scene we
got zeus who is clearly not dead as we
thought he was dead i really kind of
enjoyed that because this is a movie
about how all gods must die and not even
zeus dies because he's a god it's hard
to kill a god i don't know if that means
we get more russell crowe i personally
enjoyed the preposterous greek accent i
personally enjoyed how verbose and
arrogant the gods were because remember
that's how we met thor this all tied
back into the arrogance of thor and his
walkabout into becoming more human more
tame and i think that's going to be the
conflict with this new arc now we've got
hercules who effectively is like our
first introduction to thor and that's
kind of the purpose he serves in the
comics but zeus is going to be the
arrogant god who often sticks his dick
in places he shouldn't that's kind of
his thing if you read greek myths a lot
of the greek myths are because zeus
messes up zeus's arrogance hurts man
zeus's belief in himself and his overall
opinion of everyone else's lesser is the
arrogance of gods personified in one man
and that beautifully translates to
hercules so we thought zeus was dead
wasn't we then pan over to hercules and
we get one of my favorite character
reveals because at this point i'd
accepted that we weren't getting
hercules at this point the movie's over
zeus has been
low on people's wish list but hercules
has been high up on the marvel wish list
for quite some time personally the
character i've always seen is like oh
thor's busy or this is a great way to
show the dichotomy of what thor was to
what he's become i've always liked
hercules for the fun language and the
arrogance and the perspective but he's
never been one of my must-haves but the
internet has been lobbying for hercules
for quite some time so i was like
lukewarm to neutral until i saw it was
brett goldstein if you haven't watched
ted lasso stop this video right now get
apple plus watch ted lasso come back
it's youtube i'll be right here ted
lasso is one of the greatest shows in
the history of television not to be
hyperbolic it changed my life in that
show roy kent is my favorite character
the show is a beautiful way to show the
different ways masculinity works and
doesn't and it beautifully summarizes
what it means to be emotional and
available in therapy and i could do a
whole video about ted last but not that
what this is roy kent is a very hyper
masculine man with sensitivity that he
doesn't let show he's a very gruff harsh
honest man that's perfect for hercules
hercules doesn't need to hide anything
he's going to tell you exactly how he
feels just like
he's got a lot of those things you want
gruff he's problematic he's a guy you
want to have a lot of flagons of beer
with he's basically thor before he
learns humility and i think that's how
they're going to utilize them we're
going to see hercules in the world of
midgard and we're going to see how thor
handles that now as a father we're gonna
see a more and more mature thor not only
because he's gone in these multiple
walkabouts but we're gonna see him i
think in a very key way dealing with the
young avengers i think honestly thor is
gonna be our father figure with the
young avengers which can be very playful
and fun it's no coincidence taika ytt as
a dad has made a thor dad movie i think
that's going to directly impact how
thor's perceived going forward and then
we have the arrogant god hercules
handling our dichotomy between the two
and i think personally hercules gonna
start out as a hero that's fighting our
hero realize that thor is a hero but
come on his side and then we're gonna
meet ares i think ares is gonna be our
big villain for thor five where this was
thor saving gods it's gonna be thor
fighting gods i think it's gonna be thor
defending midgard from the gods in the
comic books often hercules is a
character that basically takes the role
of thor when thor's punished there are
times that thor's been de-powered and
hercules takes his spot i can see them
playing with that a little bit where
it's like he's being judged by the gods
and hercules comes in and then i think
that leads to aries one of my favorite
stories of hercules is actually him
fighting hulk and the commentary of why
is hercules revered as a god whereas
hulk is seen as a brooding monster so
hercules has all the strength stamina
agility and insanity of a god but he's
revered he's admired he's all the things
that hulk isn't and there's no real
difference he's a guy that's messy he's
the guy that breaks things he's the guy
that loves a drink he's a guy that has
reckless abandon much like hulk but
since he's a god he's revered and i
think that's gonna be really fun
commentary if they go that way going
forward but that all being said i think
the big villain of whatever we get for
thor five is gonna be aries he's
literally the god of war he's a god
that's gonna come down i think and start
[ __ ] with thor thor and hercules gonna
have to team up to take out aries cause
he's so powerful i think that's the move
for thor five and i think that's the
move maybe even setting up more young
avengers things but again that's another
video all right that'll do it for the
first post-credits scene what did you
guys think about it let me know in the
comments were you as excited as i was to
see brett goldstein and remember at the
end i'm gonna give you some comic
recommendations for hercules let's get
into the second one so the second post
credit scene is valkyrie in valhalla and
meeting up with heimdell again i don't
know if your audience was the same as
mine but everybody lost their mind
seeing heimdall idris elba is idris elba
you always want him there personally i
thought he was underutilized in the
other films great to see him back i'd
love to see more of them now we are in
valhalla which is the afterlife for the
asgardians if you're a warrior new dine
battle you've earned your place in
valhalla there's a great joke early in
the movie where lady siff loses an arm
and her arm might be in valhalla but she
didn't actually die in battle so she
wasn't gonna make it so they're clearly
rules for valhalla but we've obviously
lost jane foster and the mighty thor in
battle she's earned her place battling
cancer battling the battle we experience
with gore all of those things and it's a
beautiful metaphor for being worthy and
she's always been worthy seeing her
inclusion about holla was a big
emotional moment that i really enjoyed
valhalla itself is a holy place in the
comic books you don't see it that often
but they usually use it as a mix of just
with thor like drinking valhalla as well
as meeting up with characters we've lost
in the past that are worthy what i think
is interesting is we just had the field
of reads and moon knight we have
valhalla now is another afterlife there
are other versions of the afterlife
they've teased in the mcu and we have
all the stuff of the eternals along with
miss marvel with the gin all of these
different mythologies what that means
for the greater phase four and what that
means for afterlifes and gods you know
these directors talk it's not a
coincidence we got field of reads and
valhalla i think these are important
don't know what they're doing with them
yet that said i do think valkyrie being
in valhalla means we might get more
natalie portman in the comic books when
she's not mighty thor she becomes the
valkyrie the valkyrie is the ruler of
the dead she actually handles the
journey like in some myths with the
boatman and the river sticks she's the
one that makes sure you get to the
afterlife she's the one that ensures
your body or your spirit your corporal
whatever makes its way to the afterlife
so it's a very important character and
all of the other valkyries die and
that's already happened in thor ragnarok
we've already seen the other valkyries
are gone i think it'd be really
interesting if we had king valkyrie
running new asgard and then we've got
her doing the asgardian duties of the
valkyrie and she's got a really cool
costume i'm gonna give you some comic
rex because it is a very beautiful way
to evolve the character it's a great way
to move her from thor into valkyrie it's
also a great way for natalie portman not
to have to sign a contract or not it's a
great way for her character to continue
if the script is good but not tired of
10 movies we could get her back or we
could not and i think the same is true
with heimdall he thanks her for watching
over her his son axel he very
specifically has been watching from the
beginning he was guarding the bifrost
from the beginning his eyes see
everything you could bring back him
watching from valhalla we could use
idris elba as heimdall guarding over
midgard we could also tie potentially
axel into the young avengers having some
of heimdall's powers so this
post-credits scene sets up potentially
another young avenger maybe sets up
idris elba and natalie portman
potentially coming back in new
capacities and it gives us potentially a
new hero in valkyrie brand new costume
brand new character brand new ways to
use the powerhouse that is natalie
portman that i think with the chemistry
of thor has finally endeared people to
jane foster i think we can all agree we
love this take on jane foster and i
think it's a really good potential to
see her come back as valkyrie if that's
what we so choose both post-credits
scenes set up a lot of possibilities
which is again what i always want from a
post-credits scene let's talk about some
comic cracks comic recommendations for
hercules hercules i would recommend
avengers disassembled there's a lot of
really fun stuff with a drunk disheveled
hercules that's the era they tend to be
pulling some of these more modern comics
from he's been around since the 60s i
don't know if they're gonna go like you
know kirby era fun wacky hijinks but if
they go more modern i would recommend
avengers disassembled i also think the
name avengers disassembled may come into
play i can see it on a poster already
but then we've also got the she-hulk
lawsuit storyline that is one i hinted
at earlier it's only one issue it is
she-hulk number nine from the dan slot
run not that long ago also 2010s what's
fun about it is someone sues hercules
for basically destroying stuff and you
get to see basically thor s character
dealing with petty human lawsuits while
also trying to get back to work that's
how i think they might bring him into
shield civil war is the civil war
storyline that was the basis for the
movie we got a few years ago the captain
america movie what i love about him in
the civil war storyline is bear with me
it's comic books thor is not in it but
an android that is thor that someone
made people think is thor is acting as
thor in the avengers thor is trapped
between worlds at the time so there's
this basically android wreaking havoc
and hercules is aware that that's not
the real thor and he splits him in half
and yells out thou art not thor and it's
such a badass moment and it really
establishes the strength of hercules
what his tone is that whole thing and
finally smash of the titans is a one
shot between hulk and hercules and it
basically sets up that like why is the
morality of hulk different than a god
what is that duality it's a modern story
again it's one shot so you can just pick
it up and understand the character a bit
as far as valkyrie three recommendations
for you guys jane foster valkyrie was a
title from 2020 i do believe it is a
beautiful story just a mini-series about
dealing with her moving bodies from the
afterlife it deals with her being a
doctor when she's a human and someone
that's dealing with the dead when she's
a god it's a really cool interesting
commentary in mortality the other one
i'd recommend is the mighty valkyrie
which is written by jason aaron who
wrote this character as the mighty thor
for the first time he also wrote god
bomb in a lot of the comics that this
movie was based on he really knows this
character but especially the art in this
title loki has never looked cooler it's
this really beautiful painted style of
art that is absolutely stunning highly
recommend that as well and then the
mighty thor stuff that this movie is
based on does tie directly into where
valkyrie goes that is gonna do it and i
gotta say i especially appreciate you
guys in the comments saying you picked
up comic books because of koi's comic
corner you can't tell by the name comics
are important to me that was the goal of
this reaching all million of you rejects
in reject nation even one percent of you
picks up books it keeps comics alive
which keeps me alive which i appreciate
thank you for watching hopefully you
enjoyed both those post-credits scenes
as much as i did leave a comment below
which one is your favorite what do you
think it sets up how was i entirely
wrong baby i was right see you next time
thanks guys